i've seen the headlines i'm aware that
they're out there
[Music]
i said exactly what i want to say in the
book i frequently make the mistake of
comparing my career to ariana's i can't
help it
jeanette claims ariana was allowed to
regularly miss work on the icarly
spin-off salmon cat to pursue her career
as a pop star she says the show's
writers once explained ariana's absence
by locking her character in a box hey
can i have some more juice
yeah sure ariana misses work in pursuit
of her music career while i act with a
box
i'm pissed about it and i'm pissed at
her
jealous of her it's great to work on a
show where everybody gets along jeanette
is like the sweetest
but the moment that broke jeanette when
ariana came to set the day after a game
night playing charades at tom hanks
house i couldn't take it anymore from
that moment on i didn't like her i
couldn't like her
did you send ariana a copy of the book
did you give her a heads up
are you expecting to hear from her i i
don't know i don't know if she'll she'll
read the book or not but i think i think
it's a really entertaining read
regardless of who you are um so so uh so
i hope she does yeah hey maybe tom hanks
will get a heads up about the charades
thank you fingers crossed play charades
with you fingers crossed i would love to
play charades with tom hanks that would
be amazing
but jeanette's tell-all memoir now today
also contains some disturbing stories of
abuse at the hands of her mom the now 30
year old says her mom calorie counted
her food triggering an eating disorder
and gave her showers until she was a
teenager her mom died from cancer in
2013. since then jeanette's had years of
therapy where are you in the world of
your recovery now i consider myself
fully recovered from eating disorders
um i believe that recovery is possible i
think it's really hard work it's it's it
can be really challenging at times but i
think that it's worth all of that work
and i hope that i can set some sort of
example for anybody who might be
struggling now that recovery is possible
[Music]
i loved reading about your friendship
with miranda cosgrove what impact has
her friendship had on your life what
does she mean to you oh my god i love
miranda to pieces i always will she has
such a special place in my heart she
helped me
grow as a person and heal as a person
and i hope i did the same for her and i
just love her so much
is there any chance that acting could be
in your future again i'm shocked to be
saying it shocked myself like when i
have you ever had one of those thoughts
where it's like oh where did that come
from why is this happening um i had that
maybe i want to say a couple months back
where i thought you know what there
might be a way for me to act from a
place that feels really healing and
empowered maybe i write something for
myself i don't know what that looks like
i haven't gone that far i definitely
want to focus on writing and directing
but i'm open to the idea of acting which
feels like growth to me because i i had
um walked away from it so definitively
in my past which felt important to me at
the time but i'm just in a different
place now
[Music]
you